foreign
Jada where are you from originally
where'd you grow up Florida
Florida you said yeah
what part of Florida
I was in Miami and Palm Beach
tell me about your family
well I wasn't gonna call my family
you know we really have conversation
okay it'll be using my life my father
didn't really want to have a you know a
female child so
he took it out on me and my my mom my
mom and my grandma did crystals you for
me struggle their life and from how I
got onto it at 12. and
I've been doing it ever since you
started working as a prostitute at 12.
yeah and smoking crystal
this is down in Miami
this is Long Beach Palm Beach
your dad didn't want you as as a female
child you think he didn't want he didn't
want any little kids
he just wanted to have boys and I
happily to end up with
I'm sorry I happen to only have 11
Brothers
yeah and I'm the only female all blue
he had 11 boys and he wanted one more oh
he he didn't want a female kid
so he wanted all boys right so he took
the fact that he had a female child out
on me and my mom
in what ways and
physical ways physical
not sexual
somewhat yeah no my mom my mom had died
when I turned six and uh your mom died
yeah from a car crash from me and my
grandma in the car it was on my third
birthday he was about two hours in the
morning the next day and um we had a car
crash she was trying you know smoke at
the same time with driving
and uh
you know truck hit car you know
my grandma ended up paralyzed was also
being diabetic and
I was the only one who took care of her
and
she was diagnosed with cancer
I think three weeks after your
grandmother was your grandmother was
yeah my mom had already died
so you lost your mom then you lost your
grandmother too um
being the only one who took care of her
on her diabetic issues since three
and
that's how you ended up on the streets
at 12. yeah I was a runaway kid my whole
life
because my brother's always following me
with my dad's footsteps
oh my dad gangbanged and all that kind
of we didn't know that
and you know
I had a
found out that he you know that he did
that and we had drugs
everywhere I would see him but I
wouldn't touch him but didn't want to do
that because it was already enough for
me having my mental issues
I have like a very high tolerance of
anxiety and so it's like it's hard
for me to be able to explain and process
things
other people I guess because your
anxiety gets in the way my anxiety is
very high yeah so
the things that I do in sales
you know our hope to be
reasonable or
you know understanding because the
things that happen to me
well my four brothers alone my father
had six did raped me
so
yep
I had to live with that
I really didn't want to talk to nobody
my whole life I never really want to add
friends
I don't even know my family I try to
keep contact with my brothers
once moved out from dating this guy for
a year
he lived in Compton and my dad's where
my dad's from Compton he met my mom my
mom's Mexican
yeah
she just happened to be helping her
sister out in Compton I guess and that's
what he meant and then when she was
diagnosed you know pregnant with me but
he still didn't know it was a few she
was scared to talk
okay so she had me in Florida beach
and yeah how did you first get
introduced to doing this kind of work
well it's Crystal the prostitution
my mom will take me with her your mom
because your mom my mom and my grandma
did it your mom and your grandmother did
it yeah but my grandma quit but she was
a mental mind to like
tell my mom what to do in certain
situations
so
my mom was that type of person who would
have to explain to me when I grew up I
that this is what I have to do
to survive and
people that seem to care
I basically you know
they judge me for it
you know yo you're messing with this
person mess with that person
how old are you now I'm 21 now 21. I
turned 21 May 27th and my year I was
born was 2002.
you don't have children no
not ready for it
no you're not when did you come to Los
Angeles
last year
and at least
Why'd You Come here well
I was dating this guy for a year when I
visit back and forth
you know you seem pretty cool you know
one day you know last year I decided
what was it was like right after July
4th last year
and
he put me immediately on fake and it was
like damn I haven't done this in a while
but it took me back to my mom that's the
reason
you know like
it tore my life apart that I knew all
females that I basically had contact
with was doing and it brought a lot of
memories as a kid have you ever done
anything other than this kind of
sex work no my um dad's boss which is
what I refer to as a little kid as
Daddy's homie but
he sent me and my 27 year old cousin the
only cousin that actually gave a
about
actually police aside instead it's okay
no one that said you know
just what you're gonna do this is how
you're gonna do it and
it's gonna all just work out fine
that's what made me you know
make it through the day
you know I've always been a suicide okay
and all kind of so
we got set up without even knowing that
we both knew him
you say set up
I mean
like this like
we're both put in a room at different
times and just be confused with one of
us being in the room and not knowing the
other person's in the Stream I think
being approached
I wanted
I was 16.
16 is happening when I first
learned how to use a guy learn how to
use a gun to do what
my cousin
I was forced to be
told and made to shoot my gun
at 16.
my dad's boss
apparently that was the gang member you
know the leader whatever
he had
gave my dad two thousand dollars or
whatever my dad owned 2 000 being a
little
stuff about it suspicious believe me so
that's what my dad he killed but what
were you supposed to do with the gun
no I was told on my phone because it was
me being 12 that's my Dad's friend I
kept him in contact the schedule I need
help
so I get a call today in the mix of
making food
no answer the phone and I say
you know like hello who's this because
it's random number it's not under the
name I put under and
um
I need you to meet me at the park you
gotta park around the corner down the
street
this is locked down before I lived at
and nowhere I said okay he kind of
scared me because he was saying it like
so aggressive and with that being said
it scared when I was like you know
take it in and said are you okay he's
like yeah just come meet me over there
princess and I'm like okay hang up and I
go over there
Mexican card and um I'm taken to this
empty like
it's like Gala stage type
and
he put the earpiece in my ears I'll be
right back
then listen and
he told me the instructions and I was
led to like the store right there this
is the gun everything
oh I really was supposed to be at home
waiting for my cousin you know
from the store
but that didn't happen I live with him
and my cousin
was in there tied up to a chair
and blindfolded until he finally you
know was aware that it was my voice that
I had to do it
no one ever I mean he really didn't know
what that's friend's face looked like
because my dad's friend always wear a
mask and that's what made it weird
it made it weird I mean I never really
wanted to be close to me I never did I
would hardly give hugs hard to say
anything to him and you were forced to
kill I was forced to pull the trigger on
your
cousin on your cousin
mental hospital for that
detained no wonder your anxiety is so
high
okay
I've been in and out cyborg hospitals
you know foster homes
therapy
that's
certain things just even looking at a
knife could possibly trigger me
but
then doing this kind of work brings you
into that kind of yeah I never I would
never what if I would do it again
I could never
I never I regret that from that day and
I can remember every little thing had
happened
that's the only person I really opened
up to
you know
being 325 pounds in high school when I
was in that weight
did my work
well started getting like boyfriends I
only had like at least three or four
questions
since College I guess
I graduated earlier it was whole school
most of my life yeah
gotta do more I had a lot away from me
did basketball for six years
and
started doing my dragons again like bad
like I did when I was 12. I don't know
it was just something just like
unique about it it was cool Crystal
Method cracked Crystal I was like crack
but I came out here
you want to stand over there
I know
and now you're working fig
are you doing that with it with somebody
not really no it was more like a friend
directly
not up here good one white
X for me I'll think first it got to him
I went into pencils died twice
I'm sorry I ran into two Pips
I almost died twice
but
I've been through that before
so
um where do you stay do you have a room
no I don't I basically met somebody when
I came out here and escaped I've been
with him but it's difficult
a totally different story crystal meth
you probably get by without sleep right
now very easy
very easy
I Could Just Smokes folks but okay I
want to go to bed you can make good
money you can make good money on Figaro
Street yeah okay but another thing is
for me the things that are sad about me
being like like a model me being pretty
Maybe
with the beautiful skin or whatever nice
walk
I don't want to give anybody up
one thing that could happen just up
your life so bad
and
I'd always see as the drugs being
as much of the I was doing that
so
it's just that type of
it doesn't much
you've had so many bad breaks right you
uh
do you have any friends at all
that to the point where when I hit 18 I
shut the whole world up I never greeted
anybody I never really talked to anybody
I don't even like went to a restaurant
and actually ordered something for
myself
I never
want to never come out of my room never
and
no more people trying to make
communication with me I just every time
I come home
it's in the same corner I just think
drawing right and just regret everything
and cries
I was really going through a big stage
of depression
you've seen a therapist before yeah many
times I've at least 13
therapists the same answer to be said
about a year
at least
I don't trust pills
so I don't really take
a dope yeah I just can't trust people's
lives people know that because like
I'll tell them well I do this drug but I
don't want to do that drip like I
to be
so I'm not gonna do it
yeah
oh I really don't whatever
to go through this again I'm trying to
make it better but
trying to deal with a cancer
being my man
my heart
because I can't really say that like
she's very slow before
and he's the first one that I've ever
opened up to
you're the only one that
I ever said I love you too I'm the only
one that I've ever
so you know because it's not a normal
feeling that I feel every day
who's that I think thank you and he is a
he's a cancer he's I always should
Mexicans
and he lives right here on Family Video
how'd you meet him
it was like one morning I'm leaving from
the
are you dropping you know right on the
train
end up over here
charge my phone
and I don't know if somebody told me to
go to this be gently with the flag like
I don't even know about the spot
you know like I go over there and he
compliments me walking by
the Milwaukee State it's four o'clock in
the next one
um
and he's
like
okay whatever
I don't usually turn around for people I
don't say thank you I don't they love
them that'll ask questions keep moving I
realized doing that is makes me
lose so much
and this sounds so many opportunities
so he thinks that could have been best
for you
and now it's just worse
so
um I turn around and I asked me anything
I chose on someone yeah of course we met
over in portable charges
oh
I hold it all
in this day or
it's been difficult
things
at times where he says he's giving me
another chance
but it's really me giving him another
chance
his thing is he thinks it's just him
everything revolves with him
yeah you can be a cancer but that's not
an excuse you could use every time
is it not excuse at all zodiac sign
something that you are
but there's more to that
you know it's if you want to okay I'm a
Gemini and a Taurus but I'm I can be
stuck up and have an attitude issue but
I'm gonna fix that the other day
we'll make an effort to make it right
I might have had as I shut the world out
and I don't talk to people and I just
want this for myself
okay yeah you have money in your pocket
it you don't put nobody in my
yourself
so what let me still put 20 bucks in
your pocket in here and get some drugs
because we both do drugs
along with him also talking to me with
fennel on purpose hang on accident
first time was on purpose
you tried Fentanyl I haven't tried no he
did I didn't know we put in my drink
you put it in your drink yeah
and another time he did it
I could walk for a week and a half two
weeks and a half actually
the day I got back up I could not walk I
hardly could walk
I was like I almost forgot how to walk
me
I can't even see right I didn't eat
those whole two weeks I didn't know if
my eyes
but
pain
and if you knew how many times
that have had that drug
they would think that I'd be doing it
right now I've never
do that
Jada what's your biggest fear now
um
I'm sorry him leaving me oh really
I don't have family out here I don't
know my family
at the time of my ex has set people to
the point where they're so good and they
made websites fake news
um YouTube stuff like that
it's a point where they even got cops
come with me
because I was supposed to have a twin
sister
yeah we grew up
kind of together well I don't mention
her is because
I just feel like it's another meeting
went through the same thing
and me being a sister to something like
that I don't think I could ever
ever
I don't think I could ever handle it I
think I would dishonestly kill myself
I'm just saying that
imagine what she would do
you know we have pictures of her I mean
pictures of me when we look so much
alike it's like
twin but we have totally different
birthdays and cheers
two years but
how do you feel about working as a
prostitute
um
like I said I don't like it
the thing that gets me is the whole
money thing
are you having money I mean do you have
any belongings any possessions other
than what I see on you now
no this is everything you own yeah
basically
no oh yeah
I did and what about the money you made
yesterday last night
you're almost there
it's a cute
going another day
four hours more
six minutes seven seconds it didn't
matter it just takes more and more just
to prove way more that I think is way
more annoying it is way more that I've
done yesterday or just five seconds ago
just put it in like here
because I didn't believe that this is my
first time
for my first time and
he gives up too quick
you're trying to prove what to him
wouldn't be there that you love him no
no yeah
I think
tell me that I can't stand nobody
said a million times I'm going deep
without being able to say it he had a
reminder
because I've never said it
never had nobody say it
I never even could have said that I had
a favorite family with him being in
Foster I just can't
I
I walk around with you almost every day
if you don't leave me and I don't know
where you are
you see you say hey homie what's up
homeboy home girl what's up Mom hey Dad
you made it this far
yeah okay you're gonna hear from you I
am but I can still see the public you
have and after you
watching you guys like you guys have a
bond I don't
I have to possibly tell them at least
you have somebody to come on
stop doing the prostitution
like more than I've done it before
because
it's all I hear from them you're
was crazy in that person oh excuse I
made one mistake last year
it was apparently I did something with
his homie and I didn't know it was just
something I'd been introduced to him
never
in that time when I left him his eye and
with no hesitation I said I'd never do
that again and I promise that I haven't
been a stupid shade for it
still
that's the problem he stays in the past
he's working on being in the future
I guess says he loves me though
I don't believe it you don't believe it
I'm gonna try it not at least two times
harder than I tried it to show
I'm taking a step forward
I was taking beatings from almost
everybody and being with him Cubans it
doesn't matter
can't stop me
just write a bunch of things right there
and I almost had those shoes you almost
didn't make it
anybody told me he was coming
it was just pouring out like I couldn't
it was scary I didn't know what to say I
just sleep alone
is there any other life that you would
like to see
you're you know you build build towards
yeah
you like to get off the streets get off
the streets hopefully him to be with me
and okay
build something up maybe try a college
again
maybe make friends try to make friends
people remember
and I don't know
I don't know family is still
very unknown
um
I just want the best for being best man
if you didn't want me to I'm still going
to because
here's another right to say whether or
not or whether I can
I'm going through period
and although I give a handful on by him
it doesn't matter
I said I'll take the date we first met I
said I'll take it
anything
for you because I'm a writer guy I don't
give up
is that your best quality
what's your what's your greatest
strength
I'm not even alone snowfall yet
I'm sorry I haven't figured myself out
yet
but learning things on the street I'm
starting to learn who I am
little by little
at least I'm trying to
Jada thank you so much for sharing your
story thank you wish you all the luck in
the world
thank you